and that's mike tyson guys
you could be doing all of this all of
the curls
all of the lifts all of those things and
you look healthy from the outside
but and leave a greater legacy because
all this stuff
all this other nonsense is going to be
forgotten about this is garbage
i can say i bled for garbage
how you guys doing there's a video
that's been
circulating and inshallah
we can derive some benefit from what
we're going to be discussing because it
has to do with one of the pillars of the
dean and
has someone in it that you guys know
mike tyson and he got around some
brothers
buddha jack and amir abdullah
so these brothers i don't know what
happened but they ended up making a
jamaat
and praying together so let's go ahead
and before we start go ahead
and hit that notification bell subscribe
and make sure you support us on our
patreon
so you can get all of our latest
episodes
delivered to you as soon as they come
out insha'allah so let's go ahead
and start with this video and see what
got people so excited why i got so
people so excited
and how it can benefit you
if you start doing this too
so he's doing the call right now yeah
[Music]
in the direction of the first house of
worship built by abraham to commemorate
the
worship of the one god god almighty
allah
and that's mike tyson guys
and my brother buddha jack
and look how look how humble
i mean just look at mike here
look how humbling this experiences
because that's what the prayer is
supposed to do is supposed to humble
the human being the human being becomes
arrogant the human being
gets some wealth some money some fame
and the human being can become very
rebellious
very ungrateful but this
is the formula for success happiness
and actually it helps to humble the
human being to keep that person
grounded amazing and it's amazing to see
i can see why people got
excited here seeing our brother mike
[Music]
now look at that this is this is amazing
like nothing else if you were gonna
invent a way to worship the creator i
mean
can you find a better way no but this
has been sent divine from the divine
jesus prayed like this abraham before
him
moses before him and all the messengers
and prophets that the creator sent
out of his mercy and love to guide
humanity
this is how the prayer was established
by them and us today we're not doing
anything different
and you see how the human being
he's up tall and then from there he
brings himself to the lowest part
humbling himself making what's called
sajdah this is a beautiful experience
i i just i request that any non-muslim
not yet muslim out there
just to you know humble yourself right
de-stress count your blessings
count your favors that the creator's
given you put your head down and be
thankful say the creator of the heavens
and earth
guide me and thank you for everything
you've given me this is this is one
benefit we can derive from this
watching mike tyson do this
and if you're a fan of mike like many
are try it
you tried throwing the right like he
throws the left the uppercut that he's
known for why don't you try making the
sajdah the prostration
like he's doing now and establishing a
direct connection with the crate of the
heavens and earth
let me continue on so i'm get carried
away here i get very excited seeing this
now very important this is not a war cry
as the media sometimes will have you
believe
and they'll show muslims saying allahu
akbar and then they'll some things will
blow up no no this is
this is praising the creator of heavens
and earth saying god almighty is the
is greater greater than the money
greater than the fame greater than
anything you're taking a time out
from the rat race of life and you're
going to give praise and thanks
you don't need it you need it just like
when the doctor gives you medicine
hopefully it's not the drugs but the
real medicine now that's supposed to
heal your body the body
the doctor doesn't benefit from it god
almighty doesn't need any of this
allah don't need our prayers it's us
that need the prayer just like the body
you see the body needs food and water
nourishment nutrition proper nutrition
good food real food not fake food that's
not topic but
the body at the same time the body also
needs we forget about that
it needs its connection to its creator
for the spiritual nourishment that the
soul needs
you deprive the body of food and water
what happens it's gonna get sick you're
gonna start to wither away and die
you deprive the soul of its connection
with its creator
of that spiritual nourishment which this
is what it is
what happens there's a void in there and
then the heart
ends up becoming sick the body ends up
following
shortly after you get sick spiritually
sick and that's why people turn towards
drugs and alcohol and all sorts of
debauchery
because they have that empty void but
this fills that void this the salat
so back to what i was saying he's saying
allah is the greatest
greater than any of these things and
jews and christians who are arabic
speaking they say allah also so this is
not some different god jesus as i always
say
he spoke semitic language not english
and he would say allah
allah allah this is the creator of the
heavens and earth
god almighty allah is telling us in the
quran oh you who believe
respond to the call of allah
and his messenger when he calls you to
that which gives
you life that's the prayer look it gives
life to a dead heart
and the prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him he gave an example
he said
the difference between the one who
remembers his creator
and the one who doesn't is like the
living and the dead
so if the heart is dead what brings it
back to life is this prayer
allah
and also there's another ayah verse in
the verbatim word of god almighty
where allah is saying verily the prayer
restrains one from
shameful and unjust deeds so these are
that's another one of the benefits
it's helping to be conscious have taqwa
of allah
consciousness of your creator so if
you're going to go do something vile
disgusting
something bad it should be if you're
doing it right
stopping you from doing these things to
make you a better morally upright human
being
i keep saying verbatim word of god
almighty because this is not a man-made
book
you put it to the test you'll come to
know the same if you're
being genuine not disingenuous if you're
asking for guidance
and you're looking into the quran you'll
find out that there's no way it can come
from muhammad
peace and blessing be upon him from the
devil from a group of men coming
together to put it together
so if you eliminate all these options
avenues
and you erase that doubt there's only
one option left that it is indeed from
the creator of the heavens and earth and
god almighty
allah is telling us in this quran guard
strictly your prayers
guard them strictly if you fear an enemy
pray on foot while riding so there's no
excuse to miss the prayer
if you're traveling you can combine if
you're
got a backache you can sit down even if
you can't sit you can pray laying down
there's no excuse
to miss the salah because that reminds
me that this is the first thing
that a believer if you believe in toheed
if you're
a monotheist a pure monotheist if you
declare it if you're a muslim let's just
say you're a muslim now you want to
submit it to the will of the creator not
the creation
you're trying to be morally upright
adhere to the quran the sunnah
this being one of the pillars of islam
we know that this is the first thing
that a believer is going to be
questioned about his or her salah
and if this is intact everything else
will insha allah fall in place so that
goes back
to that nourishment that spiritual
spiritual nourishment for the heart for
the soul
and it goes back to what i was saying
earlier the body can look
strong you could be doing all of this
all of the curls all of the lifts all of
those things
and you look healthy from the outside
but
inside the heart is not healthy
because the person hasn't been feeding
it
with the nourishment that it needs and
that's what we
said earlier is the remembrance of allah
and that's when the hearts truly find
rest and this is actually mentioned
in the quran where god almighty allah is
[Music]
saying
those who believe and whose hearts
find satisfaction in the remembrance of
allah
for without a doubt in the remembrance
of allah
do hearts find satisfaction so
we can benefit from this being around
good companionship we need to
be around good people who are going to
remind us of our purpose in life
when we slip up they're going to remind
us to get back on the straight way
on the straight path they're going to
remind us when it's time
to make salah we're going to go back and
make salah
they're going to remind us when we're
heedless when we forget so good
companionship this is very important we
can see that when brothers come together
reminding each other
making salah together it's beautiful two
we discuss many of the benefits over and
over
salah is repeated in the quran god
almighty is reminding us
it's like if you got someone that you
really trust someone that you admire
a mentor and he's giving you great
advice he's telling you this
is how you can be successful well allah
god almighty the creator is telling us
over and over and his messenger the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
is telling us the key to success
is the key to paradise
to that success is so make sure
mike tyson i remind myself and everybody
out there all my brothers and sisters
hold on firmly to salah never
let it go no matter what you've done no
matter how far you've been away from the
dean
hold on come back to it make sajdah
leave off the things that
the corrupters of the heart those things
that don't bring satisfaction
peace contentment to the heart they
distance you away from your creator
come back to salah that connects you
reconnects you to your creator
don't fall into despair whenever you're
troubled turn back
to salah and those who've never prayed
before i've seen this for the first time
give it a try
you might have tried everything else why
not try humbling yourself
asking the creator of the heavens and
earth for guidance put your head on the
ground
like mike tyson did and the brothers
and ask just like jesus did and all the
messengers before him and the one who
was sent after him who's a messenger for
you
and for all of mankind prophet muhammed
peace and blessings be upon him
and look into islam and we we give our
our brother mike the advice who you to
give him advice said he will that's my
brother
is to use this platform that the creator
has given
him to go ahead and do because that's a
form of dala
letting people see the muslim side
of mike and no matter what he's done in
the past he can always rectify
those bad deeds and turn them towards
good deeds and be a great example
like muhammad ali was and look what kind
of impact muhammad ali had
imagine what kind of impact mike tyson
can have
if he started to really even more
get grounded in the deed lived as dean
practiced as dean share this dean and
imagine what an impact
that he can have and leave a greater
legacy because all this stuff
all this other nonsense is going to be
forgotten about this is garbage
i could say hey i bled for garbage so
this is meaningless no
at one time it meant a lot when you're
just a young kid this is everything to
you
but then you realize your priorities
change
but what stays with you are the legacy
the true legacy
is those deeds that carry on from this
life that are transferable
to the next so we'll see you next time
guys subscribe if you haven't already
hit that notification bell support us on
our patreon page and tune in here
weekly daily for more episodes of the
dean show we'll see you next time
inshallah god willing until then peace
be with you
[Music]